[Music]
[Applause]
Ramona Shelburne one of our favorites
was uh there last night in attendance
ESPN NBA Insider senior writer and for
the second straight year ESPN's NBA
coverage celebrates International
women's day today all women LED
broadcast more than 70 women on camera
behind the scenes leading the NBA
coverage Mavs and Pelicans tip off at 7
30 Eastern on ESPN tune in for NBA Today
NBA Countdown shows as well Ramona will
be part of the NBA today panel at three
Eastern good to see you again Ramona
what's that mean to you International
women's day
well you know for me it's it's something
like when I came up I was always like
the the only one in the Press Box and me
me and maybe one other person I remember
Lisa Dillman from the LA Times it was me
and her on the Clippers and then we look
around there with nobody else
um and now that now I see women
everywhere and so I think that's really
cool that it's it's uh I'm glad we
celebrate it but it's almost because
because we've done so much here
um it's not as rare anymore and I'm I'm
glad every night I walk into the studio
I see I see women there but when you
were in high school or college who did
you look up to
oh man that's Jackie Mack Jackie
McMullen right
um so I grew up in LA and I grew up
watching watching the Lakers right in
the Boston Celtics and so I think the
first time I met Jack McMullen when I
went out to cover the Lakers against the
Celtics in the 2008 finals
um I tried to ask you know try to
introduce myself and it's the first time
Dan you know me I talk a lot right very
rare that I cannot find words I think I
just I could not even talk to Jackie
McMullen I was like Jackie my name is
you're Jackie like
it's like that uh Chris Farley character
on Saturday Night Live you're Paul
McCartney
yeah and she's like yes
and I don't know if people understand
the imprint that Jackie McMullen has
left on the NBA because
like I I remember we played pickup
basketball in Chicago during the NBA
Finals she was on my team she was just
you know part of the the media she she
was not somebody different but she was
but she just she's Jackie back yes yeah
unbelievable oh you know me too like
playing college softball like you know
we we played I played Stanford and it
was like we made it to the College World
Series my senior year and that was the
year where they put the semi-final they
put the whole world series on ESPN that
was the first year they did that before
that you had to make it all the way to
the semifinals or the finals and so like
I mean that I think that might have been
my first TV appearance right it's just
being on ESPN in the College World
Series but now it's like turn on and
there's a softball game all the time
there's people you know all summer long
or all spring long we're watching it uh
how would you sum up the atmosphere last
night with pal Gasol's jersey retired
yeah it was awesome
um you know first of all like there was
a there's people who came back right so
there was you know it was great to see
Phil Jackson up on the up on the video
board he did a video message for him he
was he stayed mostly in his suite but we
haven't seen Phil in a lot of years here
so that was that was cool seeing him I
saw his whole
um the entire Spanish media was there
right
um they were uh I think I got
interviewed by seven Outlets from
Barcelona uh because he really is a
national hero there but that was
interesting Dan because he you know he
only played seven years for the Lakers
right and they won two titles in those
seven years uh but he was universally
beloved and it's it's easy to forget
like when the last year or so of his
time there it's kind of awkward right
they tried to trade him for the in the
Chris Paul trade and then there was the
other trade subsequent trade discussions
it was like kind of a messy ending there
um and so but he's he's sort of right
back into the family now and I thought
it was appropriate his his jersey is
right next to Kobe and right below James
Worthy's
um and it's like that's the kind of
player Powell was like he was
um he was such a gentleman such a great
complimentary player to Kobe like you
could not have designed a better
complimentary player for Kobe Bryant
than Pal Gasol and like the one thing I
always remember he
when they traded for him like the Lakers
never did mid-season trades never
because Bill ran the triangle and you
know the triangle might as well have
been hieroglyphics to most people right
pal literally had like one meeting he
was like oh yeah I got this okay oh wow
because he's so smart and and I think
that basketball IQ and and with him and
Kobe in terms of their basketball like
you running the triangle it was just a
seamless fit and
um it was great it was great seeing
there he had his two little kids he had
like the baby there and then randomly at
the end this is like such a random note
but it was it was like something that
sticks out to me Jimmy Butler came over
no I know okay and I and I remember I
was like doing the math I'm like wait
the Heat played in Miami last night
and they have a game against Cleveland
tomorrow night in Miami
so did Jimmy just fly who Jimmy played
with how in Chicago obviously did Jimmy
just fly on the off date to like give
Powell a hug
that's pretty amazing would you rather
have your jersey retired in the Raptors
with the Lakers or just be a Hall of
Famer elsewhere
I mean you can't be in the rafters with
the Lakers without being a Hall of Famer
so there's like it's kind of a debate
here in LA right there's a lot of Lakers
who could have their jersey retired but
they're not Hall of Famers so like a
Michael Cooper for example Derek Fisher
those guys have a lot of rings but
they're not up in the Raptors because
they're not in the Hall of Fame okay so
that's why it's like a like you know
they got a lot of jerseys up there so
they gotta they have a certain standard
and it's uh you know they're doing it
quick now too they don't wait to retire
jerseys until you go into the Hall
um but it was it was a great scene and
the only thing about pal like you know
do you remember when at the end of his
time there when Mike D'Antoni got there
and there was this big fight over
playing Powell and Dwight Howard
together because playing the two bigs
and Mike D'Antoni was like no it's just
it's just simple math you can't have two
bigs on the floor at one time and you
know it's not how it works right and pal
like really was very offensive like at
one point they brought pal Off the Bench
you remember that
um by the end of his time though
Powell's starting to shoot three
pointers
and then when he goes to Chicago and to
I think he finished up in in uh in uh
Milwaukee and uh and Portland he was
shooting threes he was shooting threes
so you can see that evolution of the
game like he just had to change because
the game changed so much like now you
have to be a stretch four or five if I
changed rosters if I put the Lakers
roster in the Clippers uniforms okay and
I put the Clippers in the Lakers uniform
how much coverage
do the Clippers get oh that's a great
question yeah it'd be every day I mean
even though I don't like like Kawhi
Leonard probably wouldn't say anything
but like people would cover him every
day and that's
um you know Paul George is a good good
media guy you know but um it's really
just it's the uniform it's the stage
it's the it's the bright lights so even
if LeBron was with the Clippers they the
Lakers are still going to be the star
yeah the Lakers it's it's a it's a Laker
in Dodger town I mean you know I do
radio in La Dan and we always we we know
the demos of who listens and what they
want and when they turn it on when they
turn it off and it's literally like if
you want to rank the top five topics
right like what gets the people to
listen it's Lakers Lakers maybe a little
Dodgers Lakers Lakers
it's literally it's like that level of
interest do you remember the first time
you sat down with Kobe or interviewed
Kobe
I don't know if I remember the first
time I remember some of the best times
right where he um
you know Kobe's like a year older than
me so I was in high school when he came
into the league and I'm like I remember
when he took Brandy to the prom that was
a big deal and uh so when I got to cover
him I just I just graduated college
maybe a year or two earlier and I think
they sent me out there to run quotes
Howard Beck was our beat writer at the
time and I was giving him a morning off
or whatever and I was like really
Starstruck because this was like the
Shaq Kobe Lakers era and I'm like a 24
year old kid just grew up with the
microphone right
um and uh and after a little while like
we took note of who was out there I
remember one time on a road trip I was
filling in and I think he realized that
this was like the first time I'd been on
a road trip and because obviously I
wasn't the regular beat guy and he was
about to leave the locker room we were
in Memphis and he touched me on the
shoulder and he goes hey
um I was about to leave do you need me
for anything
oh
my god well really like that level of
understanding that okay when I'm young
I'm not here every day but I'm clearly
filling in for the beat writer that
night and he was going to leave and I
think he kind of knew like I'm Kobe you
probably need to talk to me and you're
gonna look bad if you don't have quotes
for me right like it was just that level
of recognition where I didn't even think
I was relevant at that point I didn't
think he knew my name
MVP vote goes to who
this year
because to me like you you have to
separate the last two years even though
I know it it's going to factor in
people's mind of like whether you vote
for him or not
um but like you know early in the year I
thought it was Jason Tatum because the
Celtics got such a great start and he's
having a like a career year plus I think
he's about a two-way player
um the Celtics kind of faded a little
bit here but why are we ignoring Giannis
like they're the best team in the East
right now and Giannis is having a great
year and then and then oh just just when
you think it's it's one of those two
guys then Joel embi comes out and has an
incredible game and they beat Giannis in
the Bucks the other day with him hitting
a key shot and getting a defensive play
so I think jokic feels like the solid
front runner right now but if that East
finishes in a in an interesting way like
say the Bucks stay on this run and they
just you know build a four-game lead
it's gonna be hard to not vote for
Giannis
um or let's say Philly gets up there
Billy's been playing really well and
then B has been thing out of his mind so
I think I think it's one of those three
at this point for a while I thought we
were at five then we were down to four
candidates I think Tatum's kind of
falling out right now
um but we'll see how maybe they hit a
finishing kick so it's it's one of those
three and it's gonna be interesting as
we go to the end here uh to see the you
know yokich has such a solid case now
especially with Denver in first place
like I thought he has a better case this
year than he has in the last two but
best team in the west is who
okay let's let's let's reframe that
question okay yeah I know it's your show
but I'll reframe it okay
um okay if you had to say there's you
get one team and that's where you're
putting all your money on right versus
the best team right who do you think is
the most likely team to come out of the
West At This Moment In Time March 8th I
think I think I'm rolling with Phoenix
right I think that people have the most
faith in is probably Phoenix right now
um just because of their ceiling you
know that how much belief I have in
Devin Booker and and Kevin Durant and I
and I think my second choice would
probably be the Warriors which is crazy
because I know they just lost in
Oklahoma City last night but I I know
it's the the heart of a champion all
that stuff I just when I see them and
they're good I'm like I know it's in
there and I and I feel like I I'm never
gonna write them off until they finally
lose well we're waiting for Joker and
Denver to do something in the postseason
you know you know we're waiting for
Giannis to do something he won an MVP
and and if you give him the MVP this
year that's why I I'm I have no problem
with that but yeah I'm surprised that
joker is going to win the MVP only from
the standpoint of the media loves to
tell a different story they've been
waiting for Luca to to be that mvp and
that's not happening you know I still
look at the most valuable player in the
NBA
and I think it's Kevin Durant because
where he goes I mean he can win a
championship you know he wherever he
goes wherever he goes yeah you got to
factor him in and you know here he is in
Phoenix and we're talking about them you
know perhaps winning a championship uh I
hope you have a great day a busy day and
uh always great to catch up with you
thank you Ramona thanks you know you got
you're the only one who has more and
better bobble heads than I do I've got
so many bobble heads I don't want any
more bobble heads but for some remember
when it was the rage it was like oh you
got a bobble head and then I was at ESPN
they go hey you got a bobble head now
it's a thing yeah like everybody
probably sends you their all of their
bobble heads yes I got a lot of
tchotchkes as we like to say uh thank
you Ramona thanks Dad that's Ramona
Shelburne by the way second straight
year ESPN's NBA coverage uh celebrates
International women's day with all women
LED broadcast more than 70 women on
camera behind the cameras leading NBA's
uh the NBA coverage there Mavs Pelicans
tips off at 7 30 Eastern uh Ramona you
can see here on NBA today that starts at
three Eastern